I I think most of your American viewers
probably don't know that for a couple of
years now Canada has had a for your
economy than the US hello Bonjour I'm
Todd crane for recent TV and i'm here
i'm joined by martin mass martin is the
founder of the libertarian community
sightly québécois liebe and he's a
leading voice in Quebec's libertarian
movement welcome Martin thanks for
having me Ted
so tell me a little bit about your site
well actually you have to go back to the
1990s when essentially there was
absolutely no libertarian movement
whatsoever in Quebec except for a few
English speakers McGill for example
where were used today there were a few
Objectivists who were organizing there
and some members of the Canadian
Libertarian Party but there was no
really connection with the French the
French side I discovered those ideas
partly through Reason magazine in the
early 1990s and I was wondering like who
we believe these ideas and through you
know a set of circumstances I met
further people challenger and three
other young men like me we were in the
20s in our 20s at the time and we met in
January 95 we thought we were the only
five libertarian and the whole province
one of the group Michelle Keegan you
know went on to develop the Montreal
economic Institute which is a
free-market think tank based on ancho
and where I also work another one became
a famous columnist so you know each and
our way we we developed something ya
know I lived here during the early 90s
and I really I can totally attest to
what you're saying there was no
libertarian presence here whatsoever I
think when I left it went to zero the
ideas that were totally marginal at the
time if not totally you know unknown
today you come across them in in the
public discourse and the papers on TV
and I'm curious too about sort of the
third rail of Canadian politics the
system of health care in Canada how do
you even talk about that subject with
Canadians who can't
who you know where it's hard to imagine
almost any other system the government
is the sole provider of the funds but
also it controls all all the hospitals
the clinics etc there's a tiny private
sector with private clinics but there
are no basically no private hospitals in
Canada no for-profit establishments and
that's a debate that's been going on for
decades it's always a you know on the
front pages again this morning there's a
series in the Montreal Gazette about
waiting times waiting turns here to get
operations or very bad in the United
States we're often sort of criticized
for having very extremely expensive
health care that we we put way too much
and to spend more much more money than
we should into a health care but Canada
in many ways it's just the opposite
right there's under investment the money
and just get gets lost in bureaucracy
and does not reach the patients that's
really the main issue they don't they
don't have the incentives to make it
work better health care is a consent
continual source of debate in the United
States and dissatisfaction and I think
what a lot of people don't know and what
I remember very well from living here in
Canada is that it is also a continuous
source of debate and dissatisfaction in
Canada as well for just the reasons that
you were talking about and I'm wondering
why doesn't that seem to have the effect
of changing and creating more of a sense
of reform in Canada than it does one
reason is that in english-speaking
Canada the public healthcare system is
part of a very strong nationalist this
course you know we have a public health
care system that doesn't leave anybody
out whereas these nasty Americans have
this private system where people die
there are really very very strong
lobbies the trade unions the the health
care public health care lobbies and it
takes time but it's it's evolving one
question that is fascinated me for a
long time is the sort of false
perceptions that we neighbors have of
each other of a Canada of the United
States and vice versa in that Canada
sort of I think falsely imagines the
United States is a less a fair realm
where it just anything goes
the United States thinks of Canada as a
sort of socialist socialist country
right where the government sort of has a
lock on everything explain how that is
maybe the total opposite of what we
think it is I I think most of your
American viewers probably don't know
that for a couple of years now Canada
has had a four your economy than the US
if you look at the index of economic
freedoms of the Fraser Institute at the
Heritage Foundation Canada is in sixth
or and seventh place so the sixth freest
economy in the world which is very good
and it's been going up for for many
years actually Canada has been a freer
country than the US you know for a very
long time in the 20th century you got a
central bank decades before we did you
got an income tax before a few years
before we did you got the New Deal many
years before we did you got the social
policies of the 1960s the Great Society
a decade before we did but then Pierre
Trudeau came to power and we got those
same programs and the federal government
went much further but then in the 1990s
for NAFTA as as finance minister and
John Keating as Prime Minister
they started major reforms they cut the
size of the government they got rid of
the deficit in a few years and and from
the late 1990s Canada has been the
poster boy to some extent of the g8
countries in terms of sound finance
Martin thanks for joining us thank you